y vamos precisamente hasta ucrania con
ese enviada especial y viene sabio quien
tuvo que desalojar la tierra en la
capital de ucrania por seguridad pero
que todos estos días ha estado
informando nos de lo que ocurre allí en
la capital ucraniana
irene qué bueno saber que usted está
bien y le pregunto entonces cuál es la
situación actual de los dos combates se
reporta además la toma rusa de gerzón en
el sur y más bombardeos en khárkov
si de hecho no nos encontramos muy lejos
de la capital de ucrania y lo que vemos
es que hay un avance de las tropas rusas
sobre todo en el flanco oriental y en el
sur como ustedes mencionaban la ciudad
hertzog al menos parcialmente ha sido
ocupada hardcover es una ciudad
martirizada donde se cuentan decenas de
heridos y también hay muertos y también
en mariupol se señalan una interrupción
del servicio eléctrico en kiev han
vuelto a sonar las sirenas pero no sólo
en quien sino también en la zona en la
que nos encontramos y hemos oído sirenas
que han sonado y que nos han obligado a
bajar a los refugios antiaéreos a las
tropas rusas siguen por tanto
intentando dañar las estructuras
estratégicas de este país para golpearlo
no sólo me intente sino también
económicamente y luego con el objetivo
luego de querer
de realizar ataques más profundos a una
buena noticia es que se están negociando
un corredor humanitario según ha
reportado a medios locales un corredor
master que serviría para abastecer el
país de alimentos y también de medicinas
que como nos comentaban empiezan a
escasear
bueno irene ahora le pregunto de la
situación en kiev que se sabe del avance
del convoy militar ruso
pues lo que sabemos es que este convoy
de 60 kilómetros aparentemente está
avanzando más lentamente de lo que se
pensaba inicialmente y esto sería
también porque algunos puentes en el
camino que tiene que hacer hasta la
ciudad de quiebra han sido hechos en
explotar por parte de las fuerzas
ucraniana lo cual está dificultando el
paso de este convoy también hay
informaciones no verificadas de que los
vehículos rusos y lala en todo el convoy
que está viajando hacia aquí estaría
teniendo problemas incluso con la
gasolina que es un bien que está
escaseando en todo el país y para todos